曹雪芹创作《红楼梦》,于情节塑造方面有一个非常绝妙的构思,被称做不写之写。这种不写传达出来的信息更加富有硬极性,因为读者为了读懂故事情节,不得不参与其中,几乎评解下一世自动脑补这些不写之写。
导致读者不再是简单的阅读者,更通过脑补实现了最直接的阅读参与反馈,这对任何一不小说或影视剧而言,都是极为难得的。
《红楼梦》你有些内容完全没写,比如我们今天要说的史香云和花西人的感情,按照原住所记,史香云早年曾长居荣国府,
他进荣府的时间线,远走于后来的灵代域和学宝差。
也就是说,史香云曾经在假家读过漫长的诱年时光,这也就解释了第三十一回,史香云做课假家,专门带来四媒降文戒指,分别送给花西人、平二、金串以及冤养。
史香云给这四位压缓送戒指,就是曹雪琴对未写的,史香云的童年时光进行的一个简单补充。
若是没有西年长居家府这层关系,史香云给这几位压缓送戒指,就会显得莫名其妙十分突发。
这四位压缓之中,于是香云关系最为亲密的当鼠花西人,曹雪琴与第三十二回,曾详细介绍过这两人的交集。
吉人笑到,大姑娘听见前人你大喜了,史香云红了脸吃茶不达,习人到。
这回子又害骚了,你还记得十年前咱们在西边暖革住着,晚上你同我说的话,
那回子不害骚,这回子怎么又害骚了。
史香云笑到,你还说呢,那回子咱们那么好,后来我们太太没了,我家具住了一层子,怎么就把你派了跟二哥哥,我来了你就不想先带我了。
习人笑到,你还说呢,先姐姐长姐姐短,红着我替你书头洗脸做这个弄那个,如今大了就拿出小姐的款来,你寄拿小姐的款我怎敢亲近呢。
史香云斗,恶蜜陀佛冤枉冤在,我要这样就立刻死了,你瞧瞧这么大热天,我来了必定敢来先瞧瞧你,不信你问问旅儿,
我在家时时刻刻哪一回,不念你几事儿。
当年史香云寄居家府,家母便将习人送去服饰香云,当时的习人还叫真珠。
后来香云回了史家,家母才把习人派去服饰家寶玉,所以习人和香云的关系不是一般的好,
也只有关系好到一定程度才会让一向稳重的习人主动开玩笑,则怪香云,如今大了就拿出小姐的款来。
而香云所说的,我在家时时刻刻不念你几事儿,一定也是实话,两人交谈质量非寻常外交辞令可逼。
问题在于,草血秦并没有详细描述史香云当年成居家府的情况,单平第32回的介绍总有一种空虚感。
仿佛一切认凭作者渡转,我等读折只能衣服而行,但正如怒性先生所言,
红楼梦的可贵之处在于,敢如实描写,收中人物皆是活人,即是活人,他们的人物形象自然是极生动的,
更宝贝之处在于,人物的行动痕迹都显得许许如生。
花极人和食香云的行动痕迹存在一些隐悔的交集,这种交集非细心之独者难亏其妙。
诸君请看原主第37回,秋爽摘欧杰海唐社。
在这一回里,加碳春散发花间变腰群拆,促成了海唐时射的建立。
在这个大官节里,曹雪琴见风插针,描写了一个小小的插曲。
这个插曲便是习人向秋爽摘,所要白马脑叠着。
可能是此回海唐时射的细分过重,导致很少有独者会意识到第37回中白马脑叠着的重要性。
具不宏君所观,在此回中,白马脑叠着一共出现过三次,
第一次是在三小姐甲碳春的姓尖里。
细心的独者会发现,碳春给哥哥甲宝玉的姓尖内容里曾提到。
左蒙亲老福祖,富又数钱是儿问切,坚以先立并真亲墨记见词,和同官会爱之身宰。
从此处可知,甲碳春之前偶感风寒,甲宝玉数次前压换过去寻问病情。
还送给碳春一点先立之,一副严真亲的末宝,从后文推测。
这副严真亲的末宝,大概就是第四十回,刘老老进大官员,重人游玩秋爽摘时,所看到的内服,烟霞显骨格,全食野生牙的对连。
虽然草水清没有点破,我等独者却不可物理看花。
这副对连,应该就是甲宝玉送给妹妹碳春的。
除了严真亲的末宝,甲宝玉还送给碳春一点先立之。
重点就是这个碟子,用来承放立之的碟子,正是移红院的珍惜程序白马脑碟子。
所以仅接着第二次出现,是习人发现白马脑碟子不见了。
移红院的器具都有专门的凹槽,承放白马脑碟子的槽子是空的,于是习人向重人寻问,这才得知这个碟子被用来承放立之,送到碳春的秋爽摘了。
习人见格子上迭曹控着,因回头见秦文,秋文,设月等都在移处做真知,习人问道,这一个产丝白马脑碟子哪去了。
众人见问,都你看我,我看你,都想不起来。半日秦文笑道,给三姑娘送立之去的还没送来呢。习人道,家常送东西的家伙也多,巴巴的拿这个去。
秦文道,我何常不也这样说,她说这个碟子配上仙力之才好看,我送去,三姑娘见了,也说好看,叫连碟子放着就没带来。
家宝玉和家碳春都有极高的神媒眼光,先红的立之放在白马脑碟子里,但是看着就赏心怨慕。
所以家宝玉专门让人把立之放在白马脑碟子里,让人送去秋爽摘,看春也觉得好看,就把碟子一起留下了。重点来了,习人为什么突然要找白马脑碟子。
最合理的解释似乎应该是,看管好移红院的股董器具,是习人的本质工作。可这个答案放在此处,确实错误的。因为习人要来白马脑碟子并不是为了移红院的利益,而是要把这个碟子送给另一个人,这个人就是史乡语。
诸君且看援助此段。习人端过两个小枷丝核子来,先揭开一个,里面装的是红灵和鸡头米两样鲜果。有那一个是一碟子贵花唐征心力粉钩。
又说道,这都是今年咱们这原理心结的果杂,保二爷送来与姑娘尝尝。在前日姑娘说这马脑碟子好,姑娘就留下玩吧。这捐包里头是姑娘上日叫我做的合计,姑娘别嫌粗糙能着用吧,替我们请安,替二爷问好就试了。
批数人职验摘,也察觉到了白马脑碟子的重要性,再此处写下批语。
妙,引这一件公案,与想习人必要马脑碟子承去,何必交涉侵发如事也,故由此一案则无怪已。
原来习人千方百计要回白马脑碟子,是为了承访新鲜水果给史乡云送去。
而且习人还专门命人转告乡云,若是喜欢这马脑碟子就留下玩,不用送回来了。
也正是习人这次送东西给乡云,才让乡云得知了海童诗设的存在。
第二天就匆匆作客家府,也入了诗设,并促成了第38回的庞协验和举华诗赛。
除此之外,还有一处细节。
习人不仅给史乡云送去了新鲜水果,还送去一个捐包,
里面放着一些真线火,这处细节按核的是第32回,
虚保拆告诉习人,史乡云再加日子过的十分艰难,
经常需要熬夜做真线火,习人得知,便为自己之前麻烦乡云做真线的事,
感到万分愧疚。于是乡云,习人开始主动帮乡云做真线,
并命人送去史家。透过现象看本质,
红楼梦里的各出细节,几乎都有各自对应的情节,
即便是不写知写,其情理逻辑都是妥却合理的。
对读者而言,这是一种高阶的阅读享受。
红楼梦四大民主之首的名省,并非是随口周来的。
今天的红楼解读就聊到这里,我们下个视频再会。